All right.
And here's the solution.
To start off, let's look
at our forecast fragment query.
Since it's a join between two tables,
it's really easy for us to add
additional parameters to our query.
Now we make sure we keep
the column indices consistent.
Now we've grabbed the latitude
and longitude at the same time
we're grabbing our weather entries.
The next thing to do is to move
the function open preferred location
in map over to forecast fragment.
Instead of using shared preferences
to get these values, we can actually
get the cursor from the forecast adapter.
We can get our cursor moved
to a reasonable position,
and then build our new string
which is just latitude colon longitude.
We'll leave our comment where it was.
Finally, we just have to fix up
a few things in the code and that's it.
Well, at least for the code.
We still need to do some work
in the XML.
Let's move this R.ID.action map
now over to forecast fragment inside
of it on options item selected.
And now we've got
to do some XML work.
Let's look at our main menu.
We'll just pull this action map item out,
and we'll place it right
into forecast fragment.
All right.
One more thing to do while we're here.
One of the things Raito talked about
was wanting to get rid of
the refresh menu item.
So, let's just comment it out.
When we remove that action refresh item,
we should probably comment it out
from our source code too.
After all, you never know
when you'll want to use that
for debugging.
So, there we have it, our final app.
No longer having a refresh button.
With new exciting setting
to turn off and on weather notifications.
Details are taken care of.
I hope you've enjoyed building Sunshine.
There's still lots of things left
to do in Sunshine.
For example, we could also add
a lot more intelligent things
to its user interface.
And of course, we could make it
a lot smarter about syncing data.
And I hope the practices
you've learned building Sunshine
will help you in all
of your future applications